нешановний Міністерство оборони ви там
взагалі показилися Чи вам повилазило чи
вам волосся дибки стоїть і росте не в ту
сторону чи взагалі в вас мозги
поплавилися і за тих розкрадань які там
відбуваються в міністерстві оборони як
можна карати начмеда за те що він підняв
питання неякісних турнікетів Та ви мали
цій людині виписувати подяки що ця
людина врятувала бійців вас би там з
міністерства оборони чиновників кинути
на передову з поганими турнікетами з
недійсними а б не нормальними
інклюзивними пов'язками чи взагалі без
аптечок ви не розумієте що кожен поганий
турнікет - це є життя людини І ви
замість того щоби оперативно
позамінювати турнікети щоб притягнути до
відповідальності тих чиновників
командування медичних сил міністерстві
оборони які позакупляли китайське фуфло
яке рветься від будь-якого натягу ви
суворо догану начмеду які підняв цю
проблему